how popular is the green New Deal a
sweeping proposal designed to address
climate change the proposal put forward
by representative Alexandria Acacio
Cortez and Senator Ed Markey has
received lots of attention in Washington
but a large swath of Americans are not
familiar with it 41% Anna mid-february
online economist Hugo Poland heard
nothing at all about it around a quarter
24% had heard a lot and 36% a little in
the same poll when asked how they felt
about the green New Deal people were
split 23% supported it while 24% were
opposed a substantial 39% were not sure
Renkin filed Democrats were more
enthusiastic than Republicans about the
proposal with 42% of Democrats
supporting it compared to just 8 percent
of Republicans a political morning
consult online survey also found deep
partisan divisions Americans are
increasingly concerned about climate
change but it is too early to say how
the green New Deal will ultimately fare
in the court of public opinion how much
do you know about the green New Deal let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI